Oh what is going on you two check it out
I'm only kidding my own commercial space
in the JK offices I rented out of space
for myself and I just said okay what are
you doing here
what am i what am I doing here but jokes
everyone okay did it really good [ __ ]
does it matter you want people doubted
you for a second you fun coming up you
called me
[Music]
Oh what is going on view to check it out
so last we got into video called when
women do that guys hate and like I told
you maybe you heard it you know and of
course today we are gonna have a very
special guest she's a woman yes I know
women and they touch me sometimes why am
i bringing a woman you ask is obviously
I'm not gonna have a really good
unbiased opinion about this so I have to
bring the female counterpart so y'all
know what it is let's go number one that
Kate man [ __ ] is over you can't be
walking up to your women and telling
them that you oh my god I'll trust you
just to give a [ __ ] up text message from
her uncle on the phone why would you be
jealous mr. uncle
I mean you useless if you are overly
possessive of a woman usually it means
that you went down low self confidence
in yourself if they ask you something
how are you gonna date a fine-ass woman
and not expect other men to 1 or 2 huh
exactly she's gonna be not hot you
better be proud of that you shouldn't be
hiding it at a certain point you should
realize the same reason why you went
after her is probably the same reason
why the other men are going out there
too right do you have any idea how
stupid you look try to make sure that
every single God knows that you two are
together cool thing here is you know I'm
just here have you done somebody real
quick yeah but you are buddy hi what's
going on buy this my lady how you like
these huh you taking these oh mine okay
it's like a little rough every time you
seen a fine ass girl walk by
stop asking other dudes it doesn't would
you get there here's a better question
would she let you probably not that's
all you're saying there in the corner
with your friends by yourself and no
other women around you
okay that's [ __ ] up do you think women
are stupid enough to not know that when
a whole bunch of dudes are looking at
them saying oh [ __ ] that she didn't see
us no huh
let me tell you something Harry Potter
the half-blood [ __ ] unless you have an
in viscid
hope she soggy immature ass we're not
blind we see you and you guys not really
good at hiding it
stop with the scraggly beard [ __ ] you
see in your mind you look like this but
in reality you look like this how do you
walk around looking like the villain
from home alone Asian men especially you
have any idea how hard it is for a lot
of H men to grow like correct facial
hair stop talking about all you're used
to bees and your back in the days spec
it'd be like Oh dad you don't say like
yo lookee here
you got three chicks and kids in the
unibrow I don't want you or touch you
anyone it's because you look like a
filthy creature [ __ ] you so ugly your
hand won't touch yourself
well fellas there are plenty of more
things that's probably a lot of us guys
do that women want to talk about if you
want me to continue just go ahead and
ask for more I personally didn't want to
do this but y'all put me on the spot so
I did I personally didn't want to do
this the day we came at me and
threatened my family if later on tonight
I asked you to be my right
[Music]
okay God my glasses are fogging up in
this [ __ ] god damn it fat people
problems it's not laughing here we go
straight face banner do it and boom
there it is
that's disgusting it's all the time
whenever I'm with the guy and he things
that leave you are chuckling exactly you
should be proud of who you have she's
gorgeous and you should show her off you
shouldn't be scared and I didn't up in
the bushes you know I understand that
you from Vietnam yeah Harry taught it in
the Sorcerer's ball every Twilight and
the Prisoner of Azkaban heavy Twatter
and the Goblet of this ahead of Harry
Potter and the order of the penis